okay today I'm going to talk to you
about conservation we're going to see
what conservation means we're going to
learn about some conservation strategies
and then we're going to see why
conservation is important for mankind so
first of all we need to understand this
term called biodiversity because what
conservation does is it serves to
increase biodiversity now what
biodiversity means is the variety of
different living things within a
particular place now there's lots of
actions that people do that actually
decrease biodiversity
such as cutting down trees so we're
gonna have a look at some different
things that actually increase the range
of different living things in a
particular place so there are actually a
few different techniques that people can
do so the first one is reforestation now
you've probably heard of deforestation
which is cutting down trees
so all that reforest ation means is
planting trees now what this means is
we're providing more habitats for
animals to live and there's more plants
as well that can live so reforestation
increases biodiversity another
particular strategy that people can use
is protecting natural habitats now what
this means is certain places where
animals live are protected and people
can't let's say poach the animals or cut
down the trees within that particular
area this maintains or increases the
biodiversity number three is captive
breeding programs this means in zoos and
other places they could actually
encourage animals to to breed and
protect them in order to increase
biodiversity so these animals do not die
out and the fourth one is something
called seed banks
now a seed bank is just the place where
that stores and distributes the seeds of
rare and endangered plants so again this
will increase the biodiversity so as you
can see here are different things that
people can do that are all conservation
strategies so what is the point of
conservation how is it beneficial for
mankind so there's a little way that
I've come up with to help remember it
and that is with this thing here MC GF
MC Jeff gives us the starting letters of
each of these different strategies
because there's six kind of ways that we
need to know the conservation helps us
so number one m is medicine now lots and
lots of our medicine actually initially
came from plants so we can actually in
the future if we don't maintain
biodiversity through conservation then
we're potentially missing out on future
medicine that we can actually extract
from plants so that's one reason why
it's important to maintain biodiversity
through conservation number two a
cultural reasons now individual species
may be important in a nation or an
area's cultural heritage so for example
in America now this apologies in advance
for this awful join but in America the
bald eagle is a big big part of their
cultural heritage so as a result that's
an angry-looking eagle as a result it's
really really important to conserve
their the bald eagle population because
it's a part of their culture and this
would be true for different animals
different species around the world
that's MC next up the J is all about
making jobs creating jobs so for example
through reforestation project
it's planting trees this is a
conservation project people can actually
have jobs planting all of these trees so
it can actually through conservation we
can actually create different jobs and
some of those jobs may come in the form
of this one here number four which is
eco tourism now there is a demand people
are drawn to visit beautiful areas such
as rainforests so ecotourism can bring
in lots of money into an area and create
more jobs
yeah and create more jobs of people
coming to see and visit take photographs
of particular areas of natural beauty so
again it's another benefit of
conservation the next one is food webs
now I'm going to quickly draw a little
diagram of a food web so this is the
plant that beginning and this just shows
the food web like this so each of these
circles just represents a particular
species okay now if we don't conserve a
food web let's say a particular organism
an animal goes extinct it's always wiped
out it basically could have a knock-on
effect on the rest of the food web and
it could damage other parts of the food
web so it could have an impact due to
the interdependence of all of these
different animals so if we don't have
conservation projects it can massively
affect a whole food web and finally the
last one the final F on here is food
supply
now essentially overfishing has greatly
reduced fish stocks in the world's
oceans so it's really important
that we have a conservation we have this
element of conservation in order to
ensure that future generations will have
fish to eat so we don't over fish so
guys that basically is what we need to
know about conservation here our
conservation strategies that people can
do to increase the biodiversity the
range of different of different living
things within a particular place and
here are the six benefits that we need
to know about conservation and mcgf can
help you to remember them thank you